I kind of dropped everything back in the
UK and and look I had done a year of I I
want to kind of call it Boiler Room
recruitment back in the UK which was you
know every day I just kind of go through
adverts and call people and I didn't
quite realize being a young naive you
know 19 20 year old I didn't quite
realize that Australia is a little bit
different welcome back to another
episode of the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is heam Aus and on this
week's episode I was joined by Sam
ingell from Opus recruitment solution
you found yourself moving to Australia
in um like six or so six and a bit years
ago 2017 you moved there right yeah
obviously your your dad moved over there
for work and then uh you found yourself
in in Australia and then you've been
working for Opus ever since Sam's based
out in Australia and over the last six
years he has dominated the testing
Market in Sydney and in this
conversation we break down how Sam has
gone about growing his book year on year
how has he built this Market how has he
built relationships how has he become
exceptional at opening up doors so much
value in this conversation and Sam does
a really good job of breaking things
down being honest and talking about his
journey to all of you can benefit and
hopefully continue to excel in your own
careers with Sam's wisdom
what do you believe to be the the
quickest route to being and becoming a
subject matter expert yeah it's a good
question I mean let's get into this
week's
episode Sam welcome to the podcast thank
you looking forward to this uh nice to
have someone from Australia there's
there's a lot of people that listen to
this that um live in Australia so
hopefully we can bring uh some more
Australian recruitment stories on here I
think I've sort of neglected uh Aussies
this year I'm not going to lie in terms
of who's been on the podcast so you're
changing that I'm I'm so so happy to be
here mate honestly I'm representing
Australia there we go um so today we're
gonna break down your journey you are a
uh successful contract recruiter um as I
said to you um I think just for whatever
reason I found myself interviewing way
more perm Recruiters on this podcast to
contract looking to change that and and
you're part of that so uh as we always
do I want to start with a bit of a
career highlight re um so if if I get
any of this wrong you're going to have
to you're going to have to let me know
and correct me yeah we'll do we'll do so
let let's just do let's just do billing
because I know you've also gave me the
sort of whiteboard number as well but
we'll just do Billings if that's okay um
so ju just a bit of context uh you found
myself moving to uh Australia in um like
six or so six and a bit years ago 2017
you moved there right yeah yeah um
obviously your your dad moved over there
for work uh you had worked in
recruitment for like a year and then uh
you found yourself in in Australia and
then you've been working for Opus ever
since your world I think you described
me as like a super Niche um you actually
described it as boring um sexy it's not
sexy and it's the it's the testing
market right yeah it's the market that
um not many people really touch and uh
definitely a market that that people
give to their rookies and juniors and um
yeah look it's it's not that sexy but
somehow I made it work so yeah so te
testing testing Market testing Market
testing Market all in Sydney right or
yeah yeah so all in Sydney um and all
contract for the entire tenure so yeah
it's been very very specific but yeah
cool so 2018 this is the the Highlight
re then so we got 2018 uh Billings wise
uh that year 200 uh 253k this is this is
Australian dollars right this is all AAR
doing this she oh dollar Okay cool so
250 uh fre Grand
2018 uh 2019 434 grand um 20 uh
20750 Grand 2021 you broke the million
Mark
1.128 U million and then 2022 1.6 uh
million that was your uh best year today
and then this year uh you're on track to
do you've done 719 is so far probably
going to be on track to do just shy of a
million Billings wise yeah is that all
right that that is pretty much it in the
nutshell yeah that's that's the the
Highlight R Okay cool so we we're going
to break this down but before we start
then I'd love to get get your take on
what you believe are the common traits
characteristics habits of successful
contract Recruiters in today's market
let's start there yeah sure I mean um
you know you've interviewed loads of
guests and and everyone says a lot of
the kind of same things right um but I
think particularly in the you know in
the contract recruitment space I think I
think being a problem solver is is
absolutely number one in terms of a kind
of key trait that makes up someone who
can hunt projects and and can you know
provide the right solution to a problem
or a project so I'd say that's probably
number one or or top three I'd say um
competitiveness I've I've never met
anyone who's a top biller who's not
wanting to outdo competition whether it
be internally on the leaderboard or
whether it be the guy that you you know
stalk on LinkedIn who you know does the
same Market kind of thing do you know
what I mean so I think competitiveness
definitely comes into play
um and I think ultimately you know if
you're going to do really well in
recruitment it's it's quite a thankless
you know a thankless career in some
respects because you know you might have
loads of setbacks and um you know you
might do loads of the same input and not
get the same output so being really
hungry to succeed and wanting to build
something special um is is definitely a
key trait that that I think not just
contract recruiters but but grp
recruiters overall need to have you know
you need to want to take ownership and
and build something really uh special
and have a
USP love that so let's touch on uh I
think because I I saw your I was just
going through some of your LinkedIn
posts before this and I saw that not too
long ago you got your Australian
citizenship right that's correct yeah
yeah after six or so years I mean to be
honest I was I've always felt a bit
guilty talking about my citizenship and
my you basically have a thing called
permanent residency out here and um a
lot of my friends you know have spent
years you know trying to get their PR
but I was super lucky I came out here
when I was 1920 and and I basically was
just given a PR through through my dad
so it was nice to get citizenship but um
you know I feel a bit guilty about
getting it because I didn't have to work
as hard as other people I guess you
know so why why I wanted to just just
start there I think I I think it's you
it's it's a big part of the the the
journey and there's a lot of people uh
who uh are based in the UK that find
themselves maybe speaking to people
about potentially taking their skill set
and career over to Australia so would
you mind just talking a bit about
obviously you you moved over there with
family right uh compared to I feel like
a lot of people move over there without
their family and go over there on their
own so you were just saying just before
we started on this you you did find it a
bit difficult to to start if I may say
that like do you want to just I mean it
was how you found that initial period
when you moved over look it was it was
it was a hard time to be honest because
I kind of I kind of dropped everything
back in the UK and and look I had done a
year of I I want to kind of call it
Boiler Room recruitment back in the UK
which was you know quite literally a 100
dials a day chasing direct ads I I was
actually a like a a rookie or a junior
who was like kind of like a resourcing
role for you know Senior Team Leader in
this very very small company of like 10
people um and and every day I just kind
of go through adverts and call people so
in that environment it was quite
Cutthroat and you know if you made a tea
at the wrong time of day you know you'd
kind of be looked at funny um anyway so
I kind of took that mentality um out
here to Australia um and I didn't quite
realize being a young naive you know 19
20 year old I didn't quite realize that
Australia is a little bit different um
people are a little bit you know a
little bit more easygoing bit more
friendly out here um and even though the
office was you know full of uh quite you
know just English and Irish people
because that's recruitment right um I I
kind of bought this mentality of of you
know hard ways of doing things and and
not kind of looking at the relationships
internally or externally and um I was
kind of trying to you know fight for
myself at the start and that didn't work
well for me so you know I had to
basically relearn recruitment you know
and I had to just clean slay take on
everyone's advice be a sponge and adapt
because if I continued the same way that
I was in the UK and being a young naive
hungry kid who just you know wants to be
the best in her money um taking that
mentality to Australia just it just
didn't quite work so yeah I had to
really change um but I'm glad that I
took on advice and and did that and um
you know I'm I you know I guess I'm
quite quite happy to be where I'm at now
and if I didn't take on that you know
advice and constructive criticism I
certainly wouldn't be sitting here
mate and what what about personally yeah
how you find adapting to that yeah
personally it was quite tough because
like I came out here like I didn't
really know anyone so you know my my
entire social group was coming from the
office really and in the first six
months you know I didn't really have I
was kind of living with parents and you
know on a low basic salary not earning
much I didn't really know where to go or
what to do so I'd kind of attached to
the kind of social groups at work and
you know see you know if I can make
friends or friends of friends so it
certainly took a while um but I think
after about six months I kind of found
my feet and you know made some good
mates within the office and I was quite
lucky in in the fact that I had um shout
out to Mike who uh who was my kind of
lead my manager at the time and he took
me under his wing and and showed me the
way and um yeah it's it's been pretty
good ever since but um yeah it wasn't
without its struggles I'll be honest
with
you so to to round that out then for for
anyone that that's listening uh just one
or one or two things I guess
firstly if I'm listening to this right
now I've worked in the UK recruitment
Market I've got a good number of years
under my belt I have a degree there
there's a genuine opportunity for me to
to go to
Australia what do you think or what have
you found yourself uh giving advice to
people that come over to Opa cuz I'm
sure that that that happens now still
what are some of the things that you
find uh these people have to like
unlearn quite quickly a lot of the time
when they're sort of coming to the
Australian Market out of Interest yeah I
mean I I think in particular I think the
UK Market obviously it's very saturated
so it can be quite transactional I I'm
not saying it's not relationship driven
because anyone who's done well in
recruitment has to have relationships
right but but I feel like you could get
away in the UK of being quite
transactional and just being a pure
Hunter and not really caring about you
know how it reflects on you or how it
reflects on your brand so I think coming
out to Australia you've got to realize
that it's a much smaller Market um
everyone knows everyone so you've got to
make sure you're on you know your best
behavior and you're you know looking
good you're Brand's good um and that
you're creating relationships CU in
Australia I think it can take a much
longer time to break into a client and
you know develop that relationship
whereas in the UK you know people are a
keen on a bit of spot business and then
you know I'm not going to take you call
for a year and that's just kind of how
it is so definitely the relationship
mentality out here is is a lot um lot
more longer term um and it takes a lot
longer to kind of uh break people down
and you know get get cozy with them you
know and then secondly what about
personally if I'm friend of yours I've
I've got some recruitment experience
I've I've got a degree I've I've got
Rector telling me about how I can take
my skill set to the Australia what how
are you describing working in Australia
living living in Australia to me what
what does that sound like what are the
things that you maybe highlight to to
people that are true and maybe also some
of the things that are maybe difficult
or challenges maybe I mean people say
that it um that it rains less out here
and that's not true um it when it rains
it pours um it's just a little
bit different in the UK you get a bit of
drizzle here you get an absolute
thunderstorm so look but on the other
side you know the weather's amazing the
sun's good and I think the work life
balance out here is is really something
that a lot of people from the UK move
out here for right um you know people
that a lot of my colleagues and friends
live in Bondi or Ki which is literally
on the beach so in the summer let's say
you finish up at 4 4:00 or you've just
walked out the meeting let's go to the
beach so it's definitely a different
lifestyle out here um and I find that
you know people work quite hard in their
core hours so that they can have that
balance whereas I found in the UK it was
I guess you could say kind of like a
constant burnout I mean I I was only a
junior in the UK but you know I'd be
working such ridiculous hours and
getting you know nothing out of it and
it's just a constant reset rinse and
repeat go drinking on the weekend so I
think here's a bit you know of of a more
of a balance which is certainly
attractive for recruiters
mate yeah I I know what you mean I think
unfortunately in the UK you can't do
your core hours and then find yourself
down the the beach because it would
either be too cold or the weather won't
be right so you find yourself I think I
think for I think for a lot of um a lot
of like recruiters that obviously come
out here as well is like there's a lot
of options and a lot of choice like when
I came out here for example I came I
came via Rector really good guy um and
he gave me a load of different options
and every company that I had interviewed
had a completely different way of doing
things um which I found interesting um I
found that over here you know there's
some companies that are very marketing
driven um there's some companies out
here that you know are suit and tie but
there is very rare but there's a a lot
of different kinds of agencies out here
so um that was quite interesting when I
came here like I was I probably
interviewed with I want to say six seven
eight agencies and every single agency
was so different in their approach and
their belief system um and that that was
quite interesting when I moved out as
well yeah look this this is what I love
about recruitment is it's a genuine
career you can you're building skills
that you can apply to Future different
Industries careers that are really
helpful in life but also it's a skill
set that you can take across the world
yeah it's unbelievable whilst also so
earning some good money if you work hard
and and do the the right things yeah so
in terms of this testing market then how
how intentional was that was that
already like a market that Opus had done
a bit in was it like talk to me just a
bit about that cuz I I guess I just want
to start by just getting your take on
how important it is to have a niche and
focus because clearly that that's been
pivotal in in your career testing just
testing just Sydney uh yeah talk to us a
bit about this patch and this
intentional Niche that you have yeah I
mean um look it was it was already um a
semi- established Market I mean so we
had uh two guys on it before I came for
a couple of years I want to say so we
had a guy doing perm and a guy doing
contract um so when I came in I took
over uh my manager's kind of patch which
was Sydney but it it was never like
crazily built there was no kind of uh
super huge relationships that would give
you any more than two contractors so it
wasn't exactly a standing start but
there was a bit that I could build from
and a few relationships that I could
leverage um but I mean yeah the teser
market is an interesting one because um
you know and when you spoke to Elliot on
on that podcast about you know
JavaScript Dev recruitment um it's very
much uh it's a product that you're
selling right um you know developers are
sexy bits of products especially really
good ones you can Market them really
well um the it's an absolute flip side
with the testing Market because there is
Thousands
of testers out there like it is so hard
to manage it's so hard to like even
organize like when people ask me how I
organize my stuff I'm like it's all in
it's in my head like I just I can't
really describe how I how I've kind of
how I've kind of worked it all out but
um it's very different in the sense that
let's say you were to spec out a CV of a
tester you're going to get no bite back
you might even get one email but the
email is probably going to say that
we're not hiring right now we've got a
vendor that does it for half the pr
price so um when it comes to the testing
Market it's all about understanding the
projects their pain points and how you
can bring in resources to kind of give
room for you know the other skill sets
to to Really succeed so for example in a
project team you might have a few
developers um and maybe those developers
are are doing the testing themselves and
that's taken 30% of their time why not
bring a tester in and my my sell to
people is right well let's let's bring a
test in Hab about an automation test who
can automate all the testing and
therefore your devs can focus on what
they've actually been hired you know
hired to do um so yeah look testing is
it's massive it covers every Market um
for example let's say you've got
JavaScript developers and devops
engineers and data analysts my testers
can sit across everything so my testers
might work on some JavaScript stuff they
might do some integration stuff and
devops they might test some data so it's
a really broad patch but it's a patch
that people don't really want to touch
um and that's kind of where I've I've
I've done well I've I've made a name for
myself in this place and it works out
well for me in the end uh despite it
being so kind of big and and hard to
operate in and and kind of foggy at
times it's yeah it's an interesting
space and do you think you would have
got to where you got to if if you also
did some of the the dev uh contract
stuff or different things or did you
stay really religious with the the niche
and focus of testing and do you think
that's important I I always stayed very
true to kind of like I'm really big on
like my brand right so like I I really
want to make sure that on LinkedIn you
know I'm engaging with people I'm
connecting to people in my space I want
to make sure that when I'm sending to
clients they know that I'm really
serious about testing which is kind of
unusual because not many recruiters are
coming to them and saying hey all I do
is testing like let's talk about what
tools you're using how much money you're
spending on licenses like other
recruiters aren't doing this they're not
understanding the complexities around it
so I guess for my selling point to work
and to be you know anme in my market if
I did other markets it wouldn't quite
work um it's not to say though that I
haven't jumped to Opportunities right I
have you know uh found phow jobs which
might be the occasional sales force or
PL SQL Developer or something like that
that nobody in my company at the time
might have had a desk for um and guess
what I'm going to work after hours and
I'm going to hopefully place that
because I'm all about opportunity I'm
all about seeking you know anything that
I can I'm going to give it a give it a
go um but ultimately I'm putting you
know 99% of my time into that core
Market because I believe in
it you mentioned there this is something
that that we hear a lot so I'm
interested get your take and I think
that's really evident when I was going
through your LinkedIn content I think
that really comes across you're talking
about people asking me what I think of
the market here's my take you're
commenting on like the the contractor
rates and the the things that uh aren't
competitive and why uh so I think you've
done a really good job of that and I
think that's probably something that
people I'm sure you've heard in the
office The Importance of Being a subject
matter expert so I just want your your
take for people listening
if you know with what you know now if
you were to start this Market again what
would be your route to becoming a sub
subject matter expert as quickly as
possible is it I'm going to speak to as
many candidates as possible be a sponge
ask open questions really try and
download as much information as possible
is it I'm going to be reading x type of
content I'm going to make sure all the
content that I'm reading is going to be
about this what what do you believe to
be the the quickest route to being and
becoming a subject master matter expert
yeah it's a good question I mean look I
mean ultimately it is about volume at
the start especially if you're starting
out right I mean it really is about
candidate calls um and obviously in my
opinion like when you put a number on it
and say I'm going to aim for 10
candidate calls a day or something like
that it's not enough you need to be
doing like 30 candidate calls in the
morning you need to really have this
absolute volume and the thing is with
the testing Market because it's so broad
is some calls might be really low
quality and you might not learn much
from those calls but the calls when as
soon as you can kind of recognize the
really skilled guys the really connected
guys you really want to engage with them
and have a have a real conversation with
them and and learn more like I I ask you
know contractors and people in testing
all the time like if I see a new
framework or a new tool or something
that I don't know about I'm always going
to ask them to teach me about it and
more times than none they're always
going to explain um so I think it's
really key to kind of learn about the
tooling and learn about the different
projects and stuff like that um and and
that can really you know that gives you
a lot of credibility when you're
speaking to clients because I might go
into a call with a client and they might
be using um you know there might be a
smaller company and might have committed
to like some sort of commercial tool
that costs them like 50k a month and I'm
going to challenge them and be like hold
on I spoke to a contractor the other day
and they said that you can use this tool
and it's free what have you thought
about this so it it gives me the ability
to kind of
challenge contractors and clients as to
what info I'm getting and that enables
me to have way more engaging
conversations than hi I specialize in
this space how big is your team when
you're hiring like you want to dive a
little bit deeper um and I'm a big
believer in just challenging everyone
and and you know using what you found
out to then even if it might be the
wrong kind of thing to to to use I want
to see how they react and it just it
creates conversation you
know so you're you're saying a lot of
the the way to do it is
through contract conversations totally
yeah yeah I think contracts
conversations I mean ultimately you know
you want to be figuring out with
contractors um you know what kind of
tools they're using what's good what's
not what are the advantages and
disadvantages um and then that can lead
you on to all sorts of uh other you know
useful information that you're going to
use to obviously build your Market you
know such as hot leads or what projects
are coming up or um you know what kind
of information you should really be
going
at so let me ask you this thing because
th this is quite common when I I spoke
to contract recruiters and it's
something that their managers will most
likely be saying to a lot of people
listening so how the the way that I like
to frame this is what did Sam's
contractor call conversations where the
intention was to gather information
build credibility build relationships do
the things that you're talking about so
then you can use the things that you
learn to challenge people uh from a you
know when you're speaking into clients
these different things um what did your
call sound like when maybe you weren't
doing a very good job of that compared
to how they sound not now like was it
really transactional and it was very
obvious that you was just asking
questions because you knew there the
questions that you needed to ask like I
don't know just give us a bit of a an
insight into what these maybe cools
sound like cuz it might help people
understand where they can improve these
calls to get more out of them to build
relationships better whatever they look
like yeah I mean it's it's all about um
obviously using kind of open-ended
questions um and eliminating the ability
for them to have a dry conversation and
say yes or no um obviously referencing
other things that you you know that
you've learned from another contractor
if if they're using you know X tool why
AR using Y tool explain like you know
let's have a chat about that um and I
think at the start you know obviously it
was definitely a numbers game and it's I
think a lot of people get trained to um
you know you do that kind of funnel
technique and you just ask questions
qualify them you know what's your rate
what's your expected rate blah blah blah
blah blah um and sometimes you miss the
kind of really good Snippets of
information so and I think as well you
know bring into those calls um you know
useful information you know even just
giving them a little bit of something
before they give you something just you
know having uh you know some common
market information and just saying hey
have you heard about this and that can
really start a decent conversation with
a contractor that might be within a
Target client and might ultimately be a
key for you to find your way into that
business um so I I really believe in
keeping you know the I hate it when
people say you know the top I work with
the top 5% of candidates or 10% because
you can't quantify that right but just
speaking to the best people um based on
where they're working what they're doing
and and their
reputations um and digging as deep as
you can and getting to know them and
checking in on them um like I I call a
lot of the top people in in my space
just for catch ups every couple of weeks
you know if they're looking or you know
how's it going um and those
relationships will ultimately uh
ultimately you know enable me to find
out more about you know where they're
working or if they move to another
company you know they might spill the
beans and give me a bit of information
about how they got there um you know
what the go is you know when they're
hiring so keeping contractors close is
is really really key and making sure
that you're having really open
conversations and not just qualifying
them is is super important it's as
important as a bdal
really have you just because the way
that you're have you read the are you
much of a reader or no uh I mean I'm
embarrassed to say it but I haven't read
a book since school okay fair have you
have you have you come across the
Challenger sale no I haven't no
oh that that's I'm reading that at the
moment you should you should definitely
because the way that you're talking is
very much in line with like that the
they podcast or an audio there'll be an
audio book yeah you should definitely
check it out because I think it it's it
sort of describes how your
approaching selling which is the way
that you're talking about challenging uh
people in the market on how they do
things offering them insights using your
subject matter expertise uh rather than
yeah I think it's something I thought
you might have read it just the way
you're talking no I mean it's it just
kind of I just think it's a thing that
makes sense cuz like I think everyone
like the way that you need to
differentiate yourself is like
everyone's going in and telling people
that they're Specialists and it just
holds no weight but if you can actually
have a chat with people and dig a bit
deeper then you know if if anything in
in itself that's selling right I mean
it's just it's it's give and take mate
you know no yeah totally yeah so
something that I'm sort of learning and
picking up and I feel like you're
talking about it there is there is there
any science
behind getting good at understanding and
knowing what a great worldclass
contractor looks like it might be Market
dependent but is there is there any
science behind that that you found just
really helps you be like this uh yeah
like this is a top class contractor
because when I interviewed Elliot that
seemed to be really quite pivotal
because if you're very aware that you're
dealing with some of the the best
contractors in your SP B they're going
to be working on the best projects or
like projects that I I don't know yeah
talk to me a bit about that is there any
science behind how I can get better at
understanding more quickly what a great
when a when I'm speaking to a great
contractor what a great contractor looks
like you know you know what it really is
is PE people that are actually really
good contractors and and people that are
just good candidates in general are
engaging when you speak to them um time
and time again I speak to so many
candidates and if they can't get past
the whole you know how are you today
kind of if if they're boring me after a
minute I'm not that engaged and they're
quite obviously not going to do very
well in a business environment so
ultimately the people that are engaging
and actually decent to speak to end up
working for the best companies and
working with the best projects because
see level people business people want to
deal with people that Comm can actually
communicate on a human level um so
obviously it's hard when you know you've
got a load of CVS you know it's very
churn and burn but as soon as you start
having one of those really engaging
ation you know you just feel this spark
inside of you and you're like nice all
right let's talk let's talk so yeah it
take it takes a few what is it you got
to kiss a few frogs
right okay that's interesting yeah so
talk to me about how it seems quite
common but how fundamental has it been
for you to uh acquire leads information
Market information from your contractors
that then impact acts the projects that
you win that you get involved on the
sites that you win how like how have you
gone about that has that been really
impactful as part of this journey and
how can we get better at that for people
listening yeah I mean I think always I
mean you've always got to have your eye
on the money right I mean every
conversation needs to have some sort of
outcome where you're getting a bit of
actionable information um and I think
where a lot of new recruiters for short
or people that you know tend to be I
guess mediocre billers is they're
focused on the outcome of filling their
job and they forget that every single
call they're making regardless if it's a
contract or a BD call like it everything
holds value every bit of information you
can action no matter how big or small it
might be so you know if it's information
about you know what project might be
happening next or you know what kind of
thing they're using or you know where
they're seeing people moving to or even
just having a chat to them about oh you
know are other recruiters calling you
like what they talking about they been
talking about that company again that's
hiring um and I think going into
conversations as well and it does take a
bit of practice but um obviously when
people start out they they ask pretty
black and white questions like are you
interviewing like instead of asking
something like that just joke with them
and if you if you know that like a
well-known company let's just say it's
Barkley's bank for the UK listeners out
there and you know that Barley's bank is
iring people with that skill set instead
of asking them you know are you
interviewing at the moment say oh is
Barkley's wrong you have any recruiters
for Barkley's wrong you yet and then
that just starts a conversation about
where they might be getting calls from
and that information can then become
leads right um so I think approaching
things very conversationally um and and
being really human with your approach is
very key to to getting information that
that you can then
action and how how important again this
seems like another really important
thing it might not be the case cuz you
said that a lot of the things are in
your head but Market mapping what we're
saying about that yeah I mean look
Market mapping is you know it's it's
essentially like project information hot
leads cold leads um I'm a massive
believer in in in basically cold leads
so when I started out they printed out
this A4 sheet of paper with like 25 rows
on it with you know name of the
candidate who their manager is which
company they work for which company
they're interviewing out whatever um and
I kind of just started out getting
really religious with that and what I do
is in the morning I'd kind of I'd aim to
get about three maybe four of them
completed so that would probably be I
don't know let's call it 10 to 15 maybe
20 candidates depending on how many
leads or cold leads I might be getting
and I'll write down every single person
even if I don't connect to them I I'll
write down their cold leads because
ultimately if this looks like a
contractor it's probably going to be a
company that hires contra contractors um
so I was a massive believer in terms of
Market mapping you need to make sure
that you're spreading your seed real
wide because I think a lot of recruiters
can get really fixated on um those big
Enterprise clients that are always
hiring right um and they just want to
dig into them but the truth is it takes
you know recruiters years and years and
so many different angles to get into
these clients so basically with these
cold lead sheets when you're getting
information you need to be able to look
at those cold lead sheets some point
during your day look at all those
companies and make sure that you have a
contact point in each company and then
when you revisit those leads do you have
another contact Point um have you sent
them a CV have you emailed them have you
LinkedIn messaged them have you tried to
call them so I'm a big believer in
multiple contact points across a wide
Market um but that's not to say that you
shouldn't also Focus energy into Target
clients that would be silly to to not do
right um but I think where a lot of
people fall short is is and I disagree
that that's how we started talking is I
disagree with people that say you only
need five clients to build a million
dollars cuz I think I I think I had like
23 clients when I build a million
dollars right so spreading your seed
means that you have way more
relationships and you have way less risk
because the likelihood of all 23 clients
saying we're cutting our contractors
it's a lot less than five is it a very
quick word on our sponsors Vin Cherry
before we get back into the episode as
they have a special winter offer that I
want to make you all aware of this offer
is only available until the 20th of
December so if you like the sound of
this then make sure you get taking
action before then if you are not happy
with your current CRM don't settle
switch to Viner for zero implementation
fees plus you'll get a gift of your
choice video interviews 5003 minutes per
month which is normally £99 per month
time sheet process processing at £1 per
worker which is normally £5 per worker
per month or recruitment agency website
first 3 months free which is typically
normally between
£735 to £ 3,900 depending on the chosen
package if you also mention that you
listen to the podcast you'll also get an
additional 3 months as a listener of
this podcast so if you want to make the
most of this offer you've got until the
20th of December to get all of those
benefits check out the link in the show
notes go to Vin
Cherry so what do you have it do you
have any sort of system to Market map
then you mentioned the code lead sheet
which is just to make that clear that's
just a a living breathing list of
companies that you know have hired a
contractor in the past uh or at some
point like do you what do you have do
you use any other how do you have any
system around Market mapping and it's
it's kind of annoying like we've got
this really old database uh system thing
from like 15 20 years ago that is
literally I don't even know if it's
operating on a floppy disc or what but
um I'm used to using it right so we have
um we have an ability on this system to
obviously tag up managers with skill
codes which I'm sure most recruiters
have in their CRM so obviously I'm going
to tag up skill codes but look if I
could go and redo it today and I could
rebuild the market I'd skill code it
beautifully because there's so many
people have work with who do it so
bloody well um the problem is with me is
my market was so wide it was so um
clouded that it was just impossible to
start trying to skill code everything
because everything already was
automatically coded and there was tens
of thousands of bit of data so I found
that really tough but the way that I
managed to kind of Juggle uh stuff was
put things in my calendar um just real
simple just to remind my myself to you
know Chase leads um we had a little
column on our thing which is called spec
jobs which is where I'd input my hot
leads and my hot project information so
every day I'd be referencing that not
once a day but I'd be referencing that
up to maybe three or four times a day
because I'm a big believer in the fact
that you can't just go at leads at one
angle um if you go one lead at one angle
it's not going to crack for a long long
time right um so I had some sort of
system but it was messy and if I could
redo it I'd have a beautifully skill
coded database and I'd have everything t
up so that I could just search for
everything but unfortunately I don't
that wasn't the case okay yeah so Ju
Just to round round this bit out I feel
like we spoke about the the contractor
side quite a bit
so if I'm if I'm listening to this and
I'm two years in like in my first two
years of my contract recruitment
journey and I asked you Sam what what
should I be what are like the one to one
to two or one to three activities Hab
abits that I should absolutely just be
doled in on work on every single day
getting better at that you feel like
would really enable me to build a
successful Foundation to build uh to
yeah like to become a really great
successful contract recruiter in the
long term what what are those things one
to three things that you'd be like if
you keep really focusing on this heum
doing that every single day trying to
get better at it I think you'll be all
right what what are those things yeah I
mean UL it's it's making sure that you
are going at your Market properly and
you're being a Workhorse so you need to
be making sure that you're not leaving
any stone unturned so you know a lot of
times people can get carried away and
ignore a cold lead even if it's a cold
lead one day you know that that's going
to come back around in Full Circle and
it might deliver you a job in the future
so being really focused on making sure
that your inputs are double everyone
else in that room you need to make sure
that you are putting in a lot of effort
a lot of candidate calls but then as
importantly a lot of client calls um and
I mean from from a client call
perspective the second thing would
be discover and create a USP because
there is a lot of people in the market
um particularly in those Dev markets um
or those really highly contested markets
where everyone's coming with the same
sell I'm a specialist I've got a great
database I can you know I've got the
people um you've got to figure out what
is your USP and how are you what like
why is a client going to use you over
someone else right it can be as simple
as just asking a client you know like
how do you like to work mate like I ask
clients all the time like all right look
I get it you Pro and I level with them
I'm like look I get it you probably get
a load of recruiters calling you like
how can I be the guy that you remember
like H how how can I make a difference
and just put it to them let them tell
you um so trying to stand out obviously
in a competitive market making sure that
your sell's a little bit different um
and just being being an absolute
Workhorse and not leaving any stone
unturned is is is definitely my advice I
give to anyone starting out nice so let
I definitely want to highlight what you
just said obviously some of the things
that you said when we prepare for this
that you're passionate about is that
you're big on the hunter mentality right
what I really want to talk to you about
which I think I've really enjoyed
listening to you say is about how you
challenge the people that you speak to
you uncover problems which I really like
so I want to ask you about that but I
think also like what a smart way to
discover and understand the type of
service that people aren't getting or
want to get by asking them those sorts
of questions that you just mentioned so
when it might have changed but what what
have been the sort of common things that
these people said to you that Sam you
know what this is what I feel like I
don't get from the recruitment partner
that we've used quite a lot of the times
if you were able to do this or if you
were able to offer this or if you were
able to uh deliver this uh for us that
would actually go a long way so in line
just bringing it back to what you just
said there cuz I think that's really
smart what were some of the common
responses that you got uh from these
people that said if you do this then
actually that would be really valuable
to us what were some of the things that
you picked
up yeah I mean look it's it's definitely
in my market in particular there's a lot
of really um I I face off against a lot
of vendors that are definitely you know
a lot of them overseas Singapore India
Etc Philippines um so a conversation I
have with a lot of clients who might be
you know using an offshore vendor is all
right I get it you're probably saving on
costs I understand that from a
commercial point of view your sea levels
are looking at and thinking great we're
saving money but what is the cost to you
guys when that project isn't delivered
to the Quality that you're expecting um
you know what kind of control do you
have over the outcomes the quality um
you know you know are you finding your
team's getting frustrated because they
don't have embedded quality Engineers to
drive your products and your project
right so I always try and dig a bit
deeper than all right we need someone
it's more like okay but what's the knock
on effect and if you were to do this
like what's going to be the benefit and
what's going to be the you know the
negative to it like you you've kind of
got a and a lot of times like clients
will tell me you know we're using this
other vendor and they're offshore and
they're cheap and whatever and and
they're Stern about it but I keep on top
of them and then 6 months later you
notice that they come full circle and
they come back and they go yeah you were
right you know they totally up we
we need some people on the ground now
wait so s sorry so like so what you're
talking about there are how you you
challenge them on the problems that they
have right so you're talk to them about
okay so you're doing it this way at the
moment uh what yeah the quality you're
challenging that but sorry what what I
was asking you was you know when you
said you was asking people directly what
is it that I can offer like what is it
that you'd want from a recruitment
partner what is it that oh I see seemed
really valuable I know you're talking
about the problems there cuz I mentioned
that but I I was just curious to uh hear
from you like when you was asking that
direct question because you were saying
that's one of the ways you can discover
your
USPS like what did you find to be the
common response to Sam you know what if
you do this for us or you we work this
way or you give us this that will
actually be really valuable to us yeah a
lot of the time funny enough and and you
know clients say this to recruiters all
the time is you know just just be soft
in your approach leave me alone for a
bit um and I think you know when you're
starting out and you're really hungry
and you really want clients and want
business like you're going at it and
your Train's kind of like you know call
them every other week and and you know
spec them and whatnot instead they might
turn around and be like you know what
I'd really appreciate if you could just
send me some Market rates and a bit more
information about the kind of clients
that you've worked with so that when I
am ready I know that I can reach out and
I've got something that I can refer to
when I call you um so you know I've I've
had this kind of um this like PDF
document um of of kind of like case
studies with clients and the kind of
things that we've done and achieved and
and this is just a small kind of three
four page PDF that you know I'll just
swing swing out to to clients instead of
a spec CV or something because in my in
my market you know spec CVS don't get
much traction so you know understanding
kind of what kind of approach they want
is is really important um you know even
as simple things like look let me just
understand do you prefer emails or calls
mate because a lot of the time there's
there's some people in this world who
find it quite offensive to get like a
text message out the blue from
recruiter but in my head like I'm
texting people all the time I'm texting
clients and candidates all the time like
I don't find that weird but some clients
don't like that right so sometimes you
need to just listen to all right how do
they like to communicate what's their
approach
are they kind of a high energy or a low
energy person like are we going to how
are we going to bounce off each other
here and you got to kind of feel them
out a little bit um so yeah it's really
important to get that right because if
you if you take the wrong approach with
a client you're going to be knocking on
that door and ultimately you're just
going to piss them
off so let let's keep building on this
sort of Hunter mentality because you
shared with me sometimes that you found
people don't give up on lease too soon
um yeah can sort of get complacent with
just like sending emails uh not not
making the most out of calling people
and you even even shared to me the what
you're known for I mean you mentioned
that the cold cold leads there right is
like calling and and specifically
calling cold leads or or cold calling
right what what did I was like asking
this what did Sam's cool sound like
early on compared to how they sound now
how they're different very different
mate um so how did they how did they
sound at the start oh at the very start
like I I was given a script to my first
company and then it was very similar
when I started out it was very much like
you call someone up and you're like hi
um you know I'm I'm a specialist
recruiter you know I'm calling from this
company um you know uh and that's pretty
much it or you know you might try and
say I I'm working with this candidate
you're hiring and then they just say no
and then you're kind of new to objection
handling and then you just kind of your
tail goes between your legs and you're
like a
so it's definitely changed in that
sense like I've I've kind of over the
years I've tried a lot of things I'll be
honest I've and I've tried I think it's
a lot of A and B testing like you've got
to try a lot of different sales
approaches and coold call approaches and
find what kind of works for you and the
the thing is like the same C call might
not work with two clients you know know
you've you've got to mix things up and
mix up your approach um because if you
just keep on calling someone saying hi
I'm a specialist they don't give a
you have to really find a way to engage
them you know um and how so how how how
would they sound this year then what
what's been cuz I agree with you you got
to keep experimenting right I think
that's that's so true but like how cuz
I'm sure there's some like the way that
you do it is is a lot different now
there's a reason behind why you do it
the way that you do it you're saying
you're challenging and give them some
insight so what what what might it sound
like now if you give me a call so um
look first things first is like
agreeable statements are huge right so
when I like when I do a call call or
even just a call to to chase anything or
even if I structure an email I always
want to open my statement with some
agreeable statements I I want to
basically go in and be like look I know
to call out the blue and I won't waste
your time um I understand that you're
currently hiring in this space and let's
be honest it's pretty tough um and I
want to basically say some things that
in their head they're going to go yep
yep I agree with that and then I've
actually got them hooked a little bit to
listen to you know a little bit of an
elevator pitch because if you kind of if
you don't say something that they agree
with psychologically they're going to go
a this is just a another sales call I'm
not that interested so if you say and
you level with them look I know that
you're hiring in the space um I know
that you need these specific resources
and look let's be honest it can be a
challenging to find them because I know
myself I actually hired a project last
week to do this and it was really tough
um look I've got some people that might
be able to help you with this but I just
want to understand a bit more about
where you're at um and just keep it
really open like have a conversation
rather than going in with a cell often
works out better I find yeah nice and I
think what again what you're doing at
the beginning of that is you're you're
you're sort of showcasing your
credibility by
they that might not always land but when
it does land with people like you said
they're going oh like this guy
understands what we're going for or
understands what we may have faced and
that again rather than just being told
that you're a specialist uh that the
person that's calling you as a
specialist and whatever that doesn't
that doesn't really mean anything but
the things that you're mentioning will
actually mean something to someone if
it's if it's the right person that have
experienced some of the challenges or
things that you're discussing so it's
like credibility again yeah and and I
think like it's it's it's it's exactly
the way that I structure my emails as
well like I see people all the time Who
start out Recruitment and um you know
they they send a big email cell that
might be three paragraphs and the
reality is nobody's going to read that
um as you would open a cold call open it
with two very quick and snappy agreeable
statements that they can agree with and
they can level with and then go into a
very quick one or two sentence bit about
how you could help and ask them when
they're available not are they available
when are they available let's let's talk
presume um go with you know agreeable
statements and psychologically you're
going to get a better hit rate better
response and that's for a call call or
for an
email so what what what's been and I'm
sure there's been sort of es and flows
but for you Sam throughout your career
in building this this market like what
what's been the most consistent way that
you've landed great clients that have
had you know good good uh good projects
just what what been the most consistent
way for you in terms of Landing clients
yeah it's a really good question because
obviously everyone wants that cash cow
right everyone wants the golden ticket
or a couple right um ultimately it's
about persistence um and it's about
approaching a client from several
different angles um I mean obviously
when you're going into a client you want
to make sure that you understand the
organizational structure um you know who
your I guess you could say that your
low-level decision makers are that might
be a a technical or a test lead um and
ultimately who's the guy that's signing
off their budget that might be a manager
a development manager a test manager and
then who's above that the you know
engineering uh you know director and
then the sea level and whatnot you you
want to make sure that you're starting
to make in rows with everyone I normally
find it starts at the bottom um so it
will start with those leads um or even
contractors within those businesses and
what you want to do is you obviously
just want to network around them um and
you don't want to be sales with your
approach but you can approach all of
these leaders and people in the business
you got to remember that they are not
committed to that client forever they at
some point will be searching for a job
so it's worth their time to chat with
you because you are anme you're you know
you're a market expert and they might
want to know about rates in the market
or who's hiring so have a chat with them
about that and then once you've given
them something ask them a bit about hey
look I actually got a lead um I'm not
sure which team it was but says it was
using this Tech can you help me out or
you know how about let's meet and when
you meet them can you ask them to draw
you out an or structure like give me an
or map mate um and I've asked give me an
or map mate give me a or
map it's crazy how we we did a bit of
training on this where we're talking
about expanding accounts and the one of
the tips was ask the direct question do
you have an all chart like and You' be
surprised when many people say yes how
many times have people going yeah you
mate or
like I've never had anyone say no as
soon as you as soon as you sit in front
of someone and you bought them an oak
Piccolo I guarantee they are going to
give you that or
map I'm telling you yeah yeah so all
different angles yeah like you said
you're speaking to people that may AR
aren't going to be there forever you're
giving again then you're asking but
again it's smart the way you're asking
people like to help people right yeah so
again you're leading with can you help
me like I've heard this or someone said
this is that true or is this going on
you're you're then yeah like it's it's
different rather than working through
your uh lead questions that your
managers got you're going uh have you
got yeah like it's just going to be
sound a lot more unnatural isn't it if
it just ask the direct questions you
almost I mean obviously it's natural for
humans to help humans but like it's like
you don't want to go in smelling like a
Salesman right you don't want to go in
smelling like a recruiter you want to
come in like a friendly face who could
help them in the future and ultimately
you're going to form a relationship with
them and you're going to scratch each
other's backs and I say that to people
in my space all the time like look you
work with this company I'll be honest
I've been knocking on their door for
five years I'm not even going to talk to
you about recruitment mate because I'm
not interested anymore but let's get to
know each other because you might move
one day and the likel it is you will so
I want you to be my friend when you move
to that next company right so it's all
about thinking long term
right
what how cuz it looks like have you ever
had some like proper big hits to your
contract book cuz it looks like it's
sort of grown it's just sort of gone on
uh like a sort of upward trajectory
really like obviously interviewed ear
and he got absolutely wiped like have
you cuz I want to speak to about how
does Sam feel how does Sam think about
protecting his book because I think
that's another thing isn't it uh like so
talk to me a bit about that one like
have you ever had any of you come in on
a Monday and they've gone Sam look we
were testing for this piece of tech and
now we don't need it and there was you
had like 15 contracts as I don't know
have you ever had any like big moments
like that yeah I mean look I've I have
had similar kind of things that I've
been pretty fortunate in the fact that
in my space um they do tend to stay for
a little bit longer than perhaps in a
Dev space um which is obviously nice but
it might take me a while to place them
or to actually get that work on um in
terms of drops I mean I've had you know
some of my a clients basically saying
that they one of my one of my big
clients actually at the start of this
year basically said to me yeah we've
over spent by a few million dollars um I
don't think we can keep these contracts
anymore um so yeah I think I had about
10 people roll off at the start this
year
um look it is what it is man I mean I've
I've had I've had cases of of clients
Letting Go a few contractors here and
there throughout my career and the way
I've always thought about it is the
market goes and Es and flows it's like a
stock market or whatever like you can't
just go like that but even if you're
going like up upward directory there's
always going to be Peaks and troughs so
look I'm not going to lie to you when I
first started out and I kind of reached
the Milestone of like I remember when
like 10K a week was like the OG amount
to get to and I remember reaching that
and just coming into the office one day
think I had a few beers the night before
and I kind of put my feet up and I went
yeah I'm the man
and little did I know little did I know
that that you can do a lot better than
that but um at the time I felt pretty
good and I had a few hits early on where
it would take me backwards and I just
learned all right look this this book
isn't forever and um at some point you
got humbled you got humbled yeah I got
humbled pretty quick yeah
um but um I I I guess in terms of like
the way that I protected and I've
actually up massively on this is
like one thing that my CEO he's now the
C Craig he told me that um I've just got
to start being better with speaking to
my contractors who work for me um and I
found that really tough when I was on my
kind of build phase up to like 55
contractors in 2021 2022 because there's
so many people to look after I
just had no idea how I would keep track
of them um so being able to to do
regular checking calls and I set this up
and I lost a few contractors where I
didn't like I didn't even know they were
finishing and like they just kind of
fell off and I was like like how
have I not kept on top of this like what
what the hell and I remember coming in
one day and I was really embarrassed um
and he pulled me aside and he he told me
off he was like look mate you need to be
on top of your contractors CU this
doesn't fly and I was like yeah why did
you why do you think you was why do you
think you wasn't was it just you just
didn't how know how to comprehend how
you could stay in touch of all these
people mate to be honest it was it was
yeah 55 people is a lot of people to to
check in with every two weeks on top of
that I was going through a phase where
I'd never been this busy before and I
never had that many jobs on to juggle at
once um so ultimately yeah like I just I
had to remember the importance of like
it's as important to extend and keep
your current contractors as it is to do
a new deal like my mentality this year
it's been a bit of a slower year I have
been full force in making sure
contractors are happy extending them and
making sure that my existing you know my
existing profit is staying there because
you know the the new stuff the new deals
yeah looks good you know writing up New
Deals you know makes you feel a bit
better but ultimately um you know I need
to make sure that I'm protecting what
I've already got right so yeah big big
learn for me and and something that I've
changed uh at the back end of last year
um so yeah and and I just want to say as
well I hired a a kind of delivery
consultant guy called Logan absolute
Legend I hired him um 2022 I think it
for 2022 right and having him helped me
so much because he could free up my time
he could check in on the contractors I
could focus on the client stuff and we
just did a bit of a balancing act and
that was that was really key to uh
keeping up until that point it was just
you right oh mate it was it was
Nightmare yeah I think I I'd got up to
something like 40K and 50 OD contractors
on my own and then they basically forced
me to hire a delivery consultant I was
saying I was just going to do it on my
own and then they were like dude you you
need someone else to like make sure that
this is going to plan um and I'm so
Greatful I did take him on and um he did
really well see if you if you were to
write down the perfect client spread
that you think would make you feel
really it would it would make you really
easy to sleep at night knowing that
you're very confident going sleep every
night knowing that your uh profit is
probably going to have the best chance
of remaining the same or at least not
being completely wiped by a big
percentage what what that client spread
look like in terms of how many clients
that uh you're working with or that you
have contractors with talk to us a bit
about
that look it's it's so hard to put a
finger on it because I think every
Market is so different right um
particularly in my market I mean having
a large client spreads pretty good to be
honest with you because you had I like
spread my risk just how I've always done
my business you play you placed 9 you
place with 19 clients in 2022 your best
year it says on the piece of paper that
you Shar to
me oh I can't remember yeah something
like that yeah yeah what you shared to
me yeah I've got it up there 19 clients
P placed not including extensions so
that would be yeah right right yeah so
look I think client spread can be
debatable right I mean I came in on on
your LinkedIn post saying this is
bollocks you can't make a million
dollars with five clients I'd be pretty
nervous going to sleep at night with
just five clients um because as soon as
as soon as the Taps turn off like that
could be one fifth of your Revenue gone
so I think I'd be pretty comfortable
having anywhere between 10 and and 20
clients depending on how much I'm
looking to make how big my book is how
many Runners I've got but um I think
having a good spread of perhaps one to
three Cash cows a load of B clients and
a couple of oneoff c c clients is is
probably a decent spread to have like
2021 you had 25 clients placed with it
says on yeah
mental um what what's what's interesting
as well what's interesting as well is
looking at these obviously I'm not going
to say the the clients on here obviously
but what what is interesting is there
are there are a lot of like ones and
twos and threes and there's only yeah
like a couple there's a couple like so
20 22 for example there's like 15 16 14
1 196 and then the rest are like ones
and twos in terms of contractors which
is interesting right so again you sort
of also spread the amount of clients
that you have more than like two or
three contractors with as well yeah for
sure I mean I yeah I think it wasn't
really intentional I mean ultimately
like I I was always looking at my
shoulder there was another consultant um
who I worked with and she had like
literally two clients with like 40
contractors she was always beating me
and I always thought I really want
one of them but um you know when the
market turns sour and one of those
clients turns a tap off you know not so
good so yeah I think I just I think I
just naturally I think with my market it
just took me to a widespread and I think
that kind of came with the way that I
built my business anyway because I as I
said at the start of the call like I I'm
a big believer in making sure that
you're spread in terms of communication
you're not just focusing on those a sexy
clients somebody's got a service the
other things right and they are golden
little opportunities when they come so
and ultimately with these little one or
oneoff placements or placements where
you've done two placements in a client I
find that you can have quite a lot of
control because perhaps they don't
really hire in this space often or
perhaps they don't have a panel and it
can be quite an easy win so I think for
building your business you need to make
sure that you're keeping your eyes on
these
clients and what what I wanted to ask
you as well is because looking at these
um years there there always seems to be
a lot of
extensions like looking at the these
different numbers like
2022 um 66 extensions 48 placements 2021
uh 39
extensions like is there a science
behind getting extensions is is there is
there a science behind that is it
staying in touch with your contractors
understanding what's going on like
asking the I don't know is there a
science behind getting extensions uh
yeah I mean there actually is to be
honest um so in terms of extensions look
I mean you need to make sure that you're
on the ball really really early like you
need to be thinking about extensions
three months out so like 12 weeks out
you need to start thinking about all
right is this person going to extend or
are we going to have to Market them out
and and you know get them to another
client um so what I do is I I speak to
both clients and the contractors at the
3mon period so 12 weeks probably then
again I'll remind them at 10 weeks then
at eight weeks I'm going to start to get
really serious and be like look you know
we really need to sort this out because
I'm not going to be trying to get a sea
level to sign it off with a week to go
that's just not how I do with my
business I've got reputation here the
contractor's got to pay their mortgage
like we have to be adults here so I make
sure that I follow up on email on calls
everything and I'm very thorough in
terms of am I extending these guys CU
you know this is your Revenue you have
have to protect your revenue and a lot
of people get really focused on that new
business and they forget that this is
still your money and this is your
benchmark right that you build from um
but what what are you asking the client
cuz I'm assuming they're only extending
if they feel like they they need them
right are you like they're not just
extending it because like Sam's telling
me to like I hope not what what so like
what are you asking are you cuz again
with your approach I'm assuming you're
going how's the project looking spikes
to the contractor says there still quite
a lot to be working through there's a
lot coming through like do you expect
this to you know do you expect to need
this sort of quality of testing to still
be done in another six months time like
what are you actually asking the the
client I'm I'm I'm being pretty straight
up so I just want to Black on my answer
like I need like I'm telling the client
that you need to let me know if you're
not going to extend that contractor
rather than are you going to it's more
like if you don't extend this person
this human being I have to make sure
that they're earning money right so it
is my job unfortunately as much as I
want to help you as a client I have to
make sure that they're going to you know
they're going to go and have a job
somewhere else because if you don't let
me know they are they are going on the
market so I will I will use that with
clients and that does get a
response so to to round this out then
for a lot of people they've had a
difficult year this year do do you want
to just share anything on like your
experience of like you've been doing
this for a long time now right the
testing Market Sydney You' been smashing
it out for a long time man so how how
how does Sam think about remaining
consistent not getting complacent how
how has Sam approached uh more often not
being really engaged in in what you're
doing I'm sure there's been days where
you're like now I've had enough
for this this tested Market but
like but how talk to us a bit about that
for people listening that might yeah
might be three years in not not six
years
in I think you've got to remember this
is one of the most rewarding jobs in the
world right I mean it can be very
thankless but if you start to get it
right and you start to see little wins
little wins build up and the feeling you
get when you earn that big paycheck and
you know you're going on the holidays
you want and you buy that car and all
that kind of good stuff you have to
remember that that comes from
consistency and working your ass off CU
you know you don't get things free these
days right you can't just sit there and
expect to earn like half a million a
year it's is not going to happen so it's
just it comes down to work ethic for
sure um it comes down to remembering
that it's not a rocket ship it's going
to take time I mean some of the best
clients that I ever got took me years
and years of knocking on the door to
actually get and now I mean so one
client I had like or I still have today
he's a great guy and and he used to work
at a target of mine and I never got a
shot there um and then he start his own
consultancy he calls me up out the blue
one day and he says mate you are the
most persistent I know I want you
to recruit for
me so and that's literally how and we we
have beers now and laugh about how you
know I was just so persistent
but he thought to himself he was like if
this guy's this persistent with trying
to work with me imagine the service he's
going to give me when I need candidates
like today or tomorrow do you know what
I mean um sorry I'm just going off on a
bit of a tangent there but um that's
right yeah yeah look it it's it's really
it's really important to just remember
that you need to remain consistent um
and I think one thing as well is um and
this is still a work in progress to me
but you need to focus on yourself
outside of work as well um I think it's
genuinely important especially when
you're finding it hard at work to make
sure that you've got a healthy enough
routine because I remember when I
started out like we'd be drinking on a
Tuesday or a Wednesday and you coming
with a hammer and it's horrific
right yeah some weeks I'm not going to
lie um I was no I was 21 years old like
what in a new city no no Jud no judgment
mate no judgment yeah yeah so um but
look and and as I've got I guess a bit
older and and and learned about balance
I think you know having having a gym
routine having you know walking the dog
um clearing your head chatting to your
partner stuff like that can really help
take that work stress and it can
recharge you to come in and and be a bit
hungry the next day cuz if you just keep
going at it and then you use alcohol as
release or something like that you're
just going to burn out and when you burn
out it it takes a while to get over that
so yeah love it well Sam look it's been
an absolute pleasure kudos to you on
everything that you've you've built so
far I'm sure there's going to be more
more success to come so thanks so much
for for joining me on the Pod thank you
very much mate
pleasure